a kérdésem a következő te mire számítasz
hogy mit fogsz találni októberben amikor
a városházára mész és és körbenézel és
lesz melletted 220 ember akit akit
közelről egy részét ismered tudom de
mind a 220 embert
nem hát meg kölcsönös előítéletekkel
szembesülünk adott esetben tehát hogy én
is így ahogy mondtad vagy érintettük
hogy megismertem jó néhány embert
bizonyos szempontból és bizonyos
szemszögből ők is gondolnak rólam
valamit it gondolnak rólam valamit mint
intézményvezető mint rmdsz-es politikus
mint polgármesterjelölt akárhogyan
szerinted mit gondolnak rólad
amúgy szerintem nagyon sokan azt
hogy hogy ahogy te is fogalmaztál nem
fogom megbírni ezt a feladatot és és
össze fogok roppanni egy-egy nehéz
kérdésnél sokan azért tudom hogy várnak
és várták azt hogy jöjjön egy másfajta
hangulat a hivatalba és kicsit próbáljuk
felépíteni azt ami egyé ként megvolt
annó tehát egy ilyen kölcsönös bizalmon
alapuló újraszerveződés történjen meg
nagyon sokannak meg
mindegy nem érdekli őket tehát hogy ők a
polgármester egy
ilyen
vátozó így van négy-nyolc évente változó
személyiként
tekintenek és akkor még ebben a
kategóriában is van kettő akinek mindegy
ki a polgármester nem nagyon
akar többet vagy újat tanulni vagy
mutatni és várja azt a nyugdíjas éveket
amihez adott esetben még 30 év
szükségeltetik tehát nem az van hogy
ezek 65-68 éves emberek és még egy kettő
van nagyon sokan pedig igyekeznek az
éppen aktuális polgármesterrel együtt
tudni dolgozni együttműködni de nem
ragaszkodnak kimondottan hozzá most én
nem tudom hogy valamelyik helyes vagy
sem az semmiféleképpen nem helyes hogy
hogy valaki nem akar fejlődni vagy nem
akar többet mutatni vagy nem akar
fejlődni adott esetben a technológiai
változásokkal vagy bármilyen ilyen tehát
hogy ezeket azért én is azt gondolom
hogy valamilyen
szinten most nem akarom azt mondani hogy
irtani kell de de én azt gondolom hogy
hogy itt folyamatosan versenyhelyzetben
kell legyenek a közalkalmazottak és a
közhivatalnokok is nem olyan egyszerű
mintk
esetében szzalkát leépíteni a a
hivatalnak és nem is gondolom hogy
indokolt egyébként egy ilyen nagy számú
leépítés nyilván nagyon fontosnak látom
hogy jöjjenek új hiteles emberek úgy
ahogy mi magunk mint rmds újjá tudtunk
szerveződni és nem az van hogy mindenki
teljesen új azért vannak tapasztalt
önkormányzati képviselők is vagy vannak
olyanok is akik eddig erősítettek
bennünket aztán nem és most visszatértek
tehát hogy ezért mondom hogy nagyon sok
színű és kompakt csapata van jelen pill
pillanatban az rmds tanácsosi gárdájának
is és a hivatalnál is azt látom vissza
kell hozni embereket újakat kell behozni
akiknek eddig nem volt közigazgatási
tapasztalatuk de szeretnék hogyha lenne
és szeretnének valamit letenni a
városnak az oltárán és meg kell meg kell
tartani az értékeinket akik pedig
elfásultak az elmúlt időszakban vagy
csalódtak akár vezetéselméleti
kérdésekben vagy akár nem kaptak
kellőképpen visszajelzést és éppen ezért
nem tudtak fejlődni vagy nem éreztették
hogy hogy azért a fejlődésnek is eljött
most már az ideje azokat pedig gattyába
kell rázni
nem számítok hát most én ilyen ember
vagyok
őszintén próbálom megközelíteni hogyha
hivatali apparátust nézem nem számítok
semmi jóra tehát azt látom hogy egy
picit elfásultak az emberek akarnak
dolgozni nem kaptak k őképpen
visszajelzést nem volt talán az elmúlt
időszakban annyi örömben részük mint
amennyi jár mindenkinek aki dolgozik
tehát mindenki aki dolgozik egy kicsit
meg kell ünnepelni őket és vannak
sikeres projektek most is a
városházán vannak jó osztályok vannak jó
emberek ahol nem megfelelőek az
eredmények ott is nem feltétlenül emberi
hiba okozza hanem vannak akik nagyon
túlterheltek tehát hogy közös sikereket
meg kell ünnepelni ezt nagyon sokszor
elfelejtjük bármilyen szervezetben én is
elfelejtem az inkubátóházban az
ünneplésben tehát hogy nekem is a
kollégák akik nagyon igényelnék hogy
ünnepeljünk meg egy-egy sikeres
pályázatot egy-egy sikeres pályázatnak a
lezárását egy sikeres programot mindig
jelzik hogy hát a főnök ezt ki se beszél
nem hogy nem ünnepeltük meg ki se
beszéltük alaposan sajnos tényleg
tényleg vannak ezek a hibák és
[Zene]
én mindenkivel beszélgetni fogok
beszélgetni fogunk közösen nyilván az
osztályvezetőkkel de mindenki mással aki
ezt igényli beszélgetni fogunk négy szem
közt
is folyamatosan szerzem általan
megbízható megbízható személyekről az
információkat hogy hogy hol milyen
probléma lesz van van miért nem haladnak
úgy a dolgok vagy miért nehezebb egy-egy
osztálynak a működése erre külön
abszolút kendőzetlenül rá fogunk térni
így az elején és mondom ez a
hivatal nagyon más lesz a többiekhez
képest olyan szempontból hogy nyitottá
akarom tenni tehát azt akarom hogy adott
esetben az emberek is lássák hogy itt
munka zajlik tehát hogy ne az legyen
hogy bezárunk egy hivatali ajtót hogy ne
jöjjön be valaki és nem azért mert éppen
szendvicet majd szólgatunk hanem azért
mert annyi munkánk van hogy egyszerűen
ha bejön az ember elveszti elvesz síti a
kedves hivatali alkalmazott a fókus és
még fél órát nem tud v kell v körzet
ahhoz hogy hogy tud ő most úgy érzi hogy
kell én pedig úgy érzem hogy egy kicsit
a magyarországi kormányablakoktól is
tanulhatnánk be kell vinni ezeket az
embereket is a a nép közé tehát hogy nem
feltétlenül kell a polgármesteri
hivatalban dolgozzon minden egyes
osztály ühüm egyrészt nem kell hogyha
úgy tetszik egy nagyon banális példát
mondjak
nem jó ez a központi forgalom vagy
parkolás szempontjából sem tehát ott áll
most a polgármesteri hivatal előtt x
számú autó ami önkormányzati
alkalmazottak és elvesz elveszítünk
értékes parkolóhelyeket amiket egyébként
ki tudnánk adni vagy amit élvezhetnének
a városlakók azok akiknek kisebb vagy
nagyobb ügyes bajos dolgaik vannak egy
hétköznap a városban de viszont meg
lehet nézni vagy meg kell próbálni
szétszórni ezeket az embereket jobb
munkakörülményeket tudunk nekik
biztosítani virágos irodába tudjuk
betenni őket emberek között
vannak normálisan az emberek is be
tudnak sétálni kapnak egy kis ülőhelyet
el tudnak egy pohárvizet egy kútból
venni adott esetben hogyha várakozniuk
kell és én nem riadnék meg attól hogy a
város különböző részeire tegyünk be
bizonyos osztályokat egy inkubátorházba
egy belső felső betlennegyedbe ahol
vannak ilyen területek amiket ilyen
szempontból hasznosítani tudunk hát
bátran menjünk el a a városakok közé
ilyen szempontból is és akkor akkor
nézzük meg hát hogyha jobban lehet
gyakorolni ezt a nyitást ha többet
beszélgetünk az emberekkel meggyőződésem
hogy így lehet gyakorolni deehát maga a
polgármesteri hivatal maga az épület is
ott előbb-utóbb azért egy alapos
felújításra van szükség hát azért látjuk
hogy most nincsen morális alapunk a
központban egyébként rengeteg
nem megfelelő állagú épülett
tulajdonosával beszélgetni arról hogy jó
lenne hogyha egy egységes szép
városközpontja legyen udvarhelynek és
ehhez nagyon fontos az hogy mindenki a
saját központi házát ingatlanját újítsa
fel és egy olyan színvonalon és egy
olyan
egy olyan stílusban ami ami
székelyudvarhelyhez méltó de nincsen
morális alapunk mert hogy a hivatal is
esik szét jelen pillanatban tehát hogy
rend kell tegyünk ott is ami előbb-utóbb
így is úgy is költözéssel fog járni és
meg kell teremtsük az ehhez szükséges
forrásokat is és hát akkor már miért ne
ötvözzük a kettőt menjünk elébe a
dolgoknak amíg megkapjuk a pénzt addig
egy kicsit legyenek bizonyos osztályok
az emberek között vannak akik ott vannak
egy lakosságnyilvántartó iroda most is
el van különítve de de máshol is
egyébként meggyőződésem hogy ez szóba
jöhet
úgyhogy nagy t
emmel tényleg a lehető leg előítéletes
előítéletmentesebben fogom megszólítani
a kollégákat és nagyon nyitottra leszek
a közös munkára a közös gondolkodásra
elsősorban a közös gondolkodásra én
nagyon szeretem hogyha olyan emberekkel
tudok együtt dolgozni akik nem csak
dolgoznak hanem gondolkodnak is és
jönnek javaslatokkal hogy ez mindenki
érdekel város érdeke a munkavállaló
érdeke hiszen ő valószínű olyan
javaslatot fogalmaz meg ami könnyebbé
teszi a hétköznapjait és hogyha ez
esetleg megmutatkozik operativitásbeli
különbséggel vagy akár egy élménnyel tud
távozni a városlakó az akkor
mindenképpen beültetésre kerül tehát
hogy ezt akkor akkor meg fogjuk
valósítani mindannyiunk érdekébe meg
kell nézni a vezető beosztású
személyeket hogy ott milyen helyzetek
vannak azért vannak még fontos pozíció
ok egy városházán egy alpolgármester egy
főjegyző egy
városmenedzser tehát hogy ott ott mi a
helyzet ott mennyire nyitottak a közös
munkára ezek az emberek vannak olyanok
amik már be vannak töltve vannak olyanok
akiket olyan helyzetben vagyunk hogy mi
tudunk odavinni milyen beállítottságú
legyen az új alpolgármester az új
városmenedzser
van már ötleted hogy ki lesz a az
alpolgármester
ötletem nincs de viszont vannak
elképzeléseim és azt gondolom nagyon sok
munkát várok tőle is és egy olyan embert
szeretnék aki aki szintén egy olyan
élethelyzetbe tudja hozni magát hogy az
előtérbe tudja helyezni a várost tehát
hogy ma a család dal tisztázza hogy
akkor egy picit kevesebbet fog a
következő négy évben velük lenni mert
nagyon sok munka lesz és nyilván azt
szeretném hogyha kiegészítenénk egymást
tehát hogyha ő olyan területen
rendelkezne tudással amin én nem nem
vagyok mindentudóilván
egy csomó területhez nem értek nagyon
fontos hogy
hogy megbízzunk egymásbanm tehát hogy
azokon a területeken ő gyakorlatilag
előbb-utóbb tejhatalmat fog kapni én nem
szeretném ellenőrizni őt de fontos ahhoz
hogy hogy ezt megkaphassa hogy jól
megismerjük egymást hiszen a nap végén
és ez a
hivatali kollégákhoz is egy üzenet a
napvégén én fogom vállalni a
felelősséget mindenkinek a hibájáért és
nem akarom hogy nagyon sokat hibázzunk
tehát hogy ők is most kapnak egy
védőhálót nem fogjuk azt mondani hogy
hát ezt irénke néni annyira elcseszte
hogy hogy hogy nincs amit csináljunk és
akkor kiállunk a sajtó meg a hivatal
közösségi oldalára és elmondjuk hogy
irénke a hibás nem hogyha itt hibázunk
akkor én leszek a hibás de nem akarom
hogy nagyon sokat hibázzunk
üüm ez a ami amit beszéltünk a paretó
elről akkor összesítve egyetértesz ezzel
hogy egy szervezeten belül os el a a
munkavégzés a munkavégzés mennyisége
hogy egy szűk kisebbsége sokkal több
munkát végez két tát annyit végez mint
az összes többi tehát ez létezhető hogy
17 ember annyi munkát végezzen a
városházán belül mint az összes többi
vezetés elmélet területén ezzel
egyetértek ugyanakkor nagyon sok
végrehajtó kell a város házára és ezt
nem bírná meg
tehát bizonyos szempontból egyet tudok
érteni nyilván ez nem mondható el hogyha
itt most 220 ember helyett 16 lenne
akkor akkor ugyanígy a felét végzi el a
tehát az az állítás hogy 17 ember
elvégzi a felét a munkának és a másik
felét az összes
többi ez létezhet hogy ez ez ez igaz
legyen létezhet egy vállalkozásnál én
nem feltétlenül tudok egyetérteni egy
önkormányzatnál ezzel erre amúgy nagyon
kíváncsi leszek hogy mi az amit fogsz
majd találni ben nem is kérdés hogy
létezhet-e ez
így mindenes esetre te megemlítettél két
tábort szerintem azért van négy tábor
még kettővel ki egészíteném a amit te
meg megemlítettél vannak azok akik neek
irreleváns hogy te ott vagy vannak azok
akik neek nem irreleváns de személytelen
ühüm vannak viszont azok akik
kifejezetten várnak személyesen téged és
gyanítam hogy lesz egy olyan tábor is
akik kifejezetten nem várnak személyesen
téged gondoltam menjünk végig mind a
négy táboron és mit üzennél nekik
menjünk először a azok akik kedvelik
színuszt üüm mit üzennél nekik hát hogy
igyekszem majd úgy dolgozni hogy négy év
múlva is kedveljenek és velük nyilván ők
valamiért kedvelnek és én merem remélni
hogy inkább azért mert tudják hogy
nyitott vagyok a változásokra tudják
hogy szeretem az innovációt az
újszerűséget és ő neekik a azt üzenem és
arra biztatom hogy beszélenek nagyon
sokat velem mert nagyon nyitott leszek
meghallgatni az ő javaslata ik at és
igyekszem azt amit az inkubátorházb egy
mikrokörnyezetben meg tudtunk valósítani
áthozni a polgármesteri hivatalba is és
nagyon szükségem van rájuk mert hogy
egész egyszerűen ez a mentalitásváltás
bekövetkezzen ezt nem fogom tudni
egyedül megoldani és ők valószínű olyan
szemléletű emberek mint én és hogyha azt
látják minden irodában hogy hogy van egy
ember aki ezt képviseli akkor az adott
irodában is könnyebben
fognak megváltozni vagy könnyebben
fognak nyitani a lakosság fele nagyon
elcsépelt megint ez a lakosságbarát
önkormányzat de én nagyon azt akarom
hogy mi azok legyünk és tudom hogy
nagyon sok olyan akadály van ami miatt
egyes osztályuk ezt nem tudják megtenni
mertogy hálátran a feladatuk
gyakorlatilag de őket is arra fogom
biztatni hogy őszinteséggel adott
esetben nyers őszinteséggel is tehát el
kell mondani a város rakónak azt is ami
fáj
ezt ezt meg lehet küszöbölni és akkor
csak mondjuk úgy el az őszinte helyzetet
hogy hogy lehet hogy csak egy kávét kell
adni még a még a velem szemben ülő
félnek szóval arra kérem őket hogy hogy
legyenek őszinték mindig és hogyha
bármilyen olyan ötrletük van amik úgy
érzik hogy segíthetik a közös munkát
akkor jelezzék van-e valami amit külön
azoknak üzensz akik nem kedvelik szíuszt
és nem várják hogy te odamenj mert ez
úgy úgy tűn nekem mint hogyha valójában
mindenkinek üzented volna amit most
mondtál
szeretném megérteni hogy ez miért
történhet meg
nyilván nem fogják a szemedbe mondani
nyilván hogy nem fogják a szemembe
mondani de nyilván valamiért nem
kedvelnek és az egyébként nem jóm tehát
nem jó egy olyan főnökkel együtt
dolgozni ráadásul ez egyezzünk meg hogy
négy év valószínű így is úgy is lesz ha
nagyon nagyot nem
hibázok én azt gondolom hogy ha valaki
úgy érzi hogy hogy nem fogjuk tudni
megkapni a közös hangot mert mert nem
nem szívesen dolgozna velem együtt nem
tart
szimpatikusnak nem értékeli kimondottan
azt a szakmái múltat amit amit magam
mögött hagyok hogy hogy ne szenvedjen
akkor üljünkre beszélgessük meg nézzük
meg van-e esetleg olyan al inézmény ahol
jól érezné magát vagy nézze meg hogy
nem-e járna jobban hogyha egy olyan
főnöke lenne akit szeretne
szóval mi van ha csendesen szabotál arra
rájövök és akkor mi lesz hogyha
csendesen szabotál tehát hogy itt megint
egy olyan dolog van
amiről nagyon keveset beszélünk hogy
nagyon nehéz közhivatalnokokat
elbocsátani vagy arra rávenni hogy ők el
elhagyják a polgármester nehéz de nem
lehetetlen különféle példák vannak erre
vannak nagyon extrém példák a legtöbben
fel szokták hozni a nagyváradi
polgármester bolozsán ha nem tévedek aki
nagyváradot
egy nagyon szép fejlődő pályára
állította és utána azt mondta és
teljesen önként hogy elég volt ő elmenne
a megyei tanács élére óriás többséggel
választották meg és az első
indtészkedése az volt hogy hát majdnem
ilyen parató el mentén nem pont ilyen
arányban de a a kollégáknak a felét
elbocsátotta osztályokat szüntetett meg
teljesen új ember ket vitt oda és ők ő
vele szoktak érvelni azok akik akik
nagyon támogatják azt hogy ilyen óriás
forradalom legyen hivatalokban de ezt
nem szabad elfelejteni hogy ő is
rengeteg perrel szembesült és nagyon sok
per most jár le tehát ennek az árát ők
is most fogják megfizetni vagy most
fizetgetik meg nem ilyen egyértelmű a
dolog de viszont az sem igaz a másik
oldalon hogy lehetetlen lenne elküldeni
okosan jól felépítve kell aki nem akar
dolgozni akiem nem tud dolgozni aki nem
nyitott a változásra az egész egyszerűen
nem lesz amit keressen napvégén a
polgármesteri hivatalban tehát én nem
tudok olyan én a kollégáknak is mindig
jelzem és van amikor el tudom fogadni az
érveiket hogy rossz napjuk van olyan
élethelyzetben vannak én nem tudok olyan
emberrel dolgozni akinek a szemében nem
látok egyfajta lelkesedést és én
észreveszem hogy valaki lelkes vagy nem
tehát tényleg nagyon fontosnak látom azt
hogy hogy egy irányba húzzunk
és azt is megértem hogyha esetleg néha
az evező elkalódik de húzzon valamerre
húzzon
mármint lehetőleg abba az irányba
lehetőleg abba az irányba azért
igen
szóval aki egyáltalán nem akar velem
dolgozni azt azt tényleg azt mondom hogy
a saját maga érdekében nézze meg hogy
nem-e talál máshol nagyon nagy
munkaerőigény van a város
vállalkozásainál ezek az emberek azért
zömmel én azt gondolom hogy értékesek
tudnak lenni tehát nincs nincs az a
probléma ha valaki nem szereti a főnököt
tehát hogy ezzel ez e teljesen
természetes emberi vonás emberi
tulajdonság de hogy ne menjen ez rá az
egészségére hogy ne menjen ez rá arra a
16 órára amit nem a munkahelyén tölt és
ne mutatkozzon meg alvatalanságban vagy
családbalii konfliktusba is én azt
gondolom hogy ha valaki egyáltalán nem
szeret vagy úgy érzi hogy van egy olyan
konfliktusunk ami
áthidalhatatlan akkor egy kicsit nézzem
szét azért a munkaerőpiacon tehát hogyha
most én összegezni szeretném azt amit az
elmúlt 20 percben mondtál lásom hogy jól
megértettem-e szeretnél egy gyökeres
változást hozni ide udvarhelyre ezért
fogtál neki ennek a a a ennek a
felkérésnek és ezért léptél bele ebbe a
a cipőbe mert hát gyökerest azt nem úgy
értem hogy mindent meg fogunk fordítani
h szeretnél egy egy radikális megújulást
olyan területeken ahol látod a
potenciálját ahol nem történt meg eddig
ahol dühös voltál ahol hogy miért nem
történik meg pedig megtörténhetne ez egy
rengeteg konfliktussal járó
rengeteg munkával járó feladat lesz és
elhívod a városháza alkalmazottait hogy
vegyenek részt ebbe ha részt vesznek
akkor akkor nagyon jól fogtok jönni
egymással ugyanis neked az a terved hogy
együtt dolgozz velük hogy a lehető
legtöbb dolgot delegálj hogy ne
mikromenedzserk egy hogy felelősséget
igazi felelősséget adj a kezükbe és egy
kaland legyen a munka együtt viszont
hogyha nem akarnak ebben részt venni
akkor minél hamarabb tudatosítsák ezt
magukba mert mert ezt így is úgy is
észre fogod venni ezt jól
összeösszegeztem nagyjából igen annyival
azért
kiegészíteném hogy ez a gyökeres és
radikális változás ami nagyon meredeken
hangzik adott esetben az azért
nem azt jelenti hogy valami nagyon
komplex vagy valami nagyon egyedit
terveznék azt szeretném most
konyhanyerre lefordítani
leforordítsam hogy mindig meleg legyen a
leves mert ez a leves kihűlt és nagyon
régóta kihűlt és nagyon régóta úgy adunk
levest az embereknek hogy vagy nem azt a
levest kapják amit kértek vagy pedig egy
hideg levest kaptak tehát természetes
dolgokat szeretnék bevezetni
őszinteséget nyitást várok
munkabíróképességet várok
a magam részéről pedig igyekszem
melléteni azt ami vezetői kompetencia
hogy mindig legyen munka hogy mindig
legyenek projektek hogy mindig legyenek
kihívások hogy megünnepeljük hogyha van
egy-egy sikerünk és és hogy jó legyen a
hangulat mert hogy azért az is
számít nagyon fontosnak látom azt és
erről meg megint csak majd személyesen
fogok tudok meg tudni meggyőződni hogy
itt jó kollégák legyenek hogy ismerjék
meg egymást az emberek hogy ne halljam
azt négy év múlva hogy valaki
rendszeresen munkaidőben jár fogylászhoz
kozmetikába turkálóba nézelődni hanem én
nem mondom hogy nem kell kiszapkadni az
irodai környezetből legyen egy jó kávézó
ahol beszélget egymással két olyan
munkatárs aki nem egy irodában van de
mégis csak egy hivatalért és egy ügyért
küzd tehát hogy hogy igen nyugodtan
lehet kávézni nyugodtan lehet
beszélgetni ilyen jellegű változások
lesznek de én azt gondolom hogy ezek
természetesek